knowing that that's just defense her
husband Richard first in the doorman
thing about the end of the world
you know Snoop Dogg smokes on camera
they give up pistachio commercial you
and me can't get the last 15 years
everybody knows I smoke weed we go into
a thing we say something interesting
runs when I saw that captain win special
first time that lady apparently told me
she goes he became the star way before
he even said a word out of his mouth it
was when he was in the car was smoking
with sure that's when he became a star
you know this is garbage
yeah it doesn't see how big it was at
least not that I've seen but oh here we
go Hey
yeah they must be sold in increments of
10 milligrams
Seattle oh [ __ ] what will here
[ __ ] oh Jesus
hey goalies I am it's that time
[ __ ] Wednesday afternoon you
ain't doing dick anyway right or wrong
you're sitting there like a monster
monster wait for the bell to go off
maybe in the East Coast you're on your
way home that's it we're here smoking
dope having a good time Hornet [ __ ] can
we beam all the [ __ ] man-made stars
that can't be big
all these [ __ ] agency network stars
they can't do big I keep getting these
message from these people we have
important documents for your name listen
I would call them back you're getting
spam on personal comments no I'm getting
spam on pause
we got more here I'm saying don't be shy
I met a Cuban kids ahead jiu-jitsu he
says his wife cooks all the [ __ ] time
in Glendale we got family we're going
over soonish
this is my wife's pork people go bananas
yeah I did yeah
got a good time that's amazing he didn't
know yeah he was the roosterteeth others
with me his father what's up [ __ ]
get ready
that's right we're going deep today let
me tell you something I've been doing
jiu-jitsu at Randolph since we give each
other then he can do it to me at the
store you don't like it anyway Mike he
walks in with a doctor bag he's gonna
top the bag to put his D hilarious round
back
the leather brown bag right
I use that bad
strap right but he's a good guy he's at
the Comedy Store he cares I'm
comfortable with them because he sees
all my sentence I'm saying is that time
afternoon it's always that time
afternoon blood stars at that you know
periscope you look a little hard without
thankful I wish you were here nobody
loses
get ready we'll try one of those why I
could do this
I'm going to pull a Cosmo
four fully and floor for me
a thousand my question to babysit
tonight
I am in Omaha Nebraska at the [ __ ]
corn Husker Ville wisdom University
Lincoln that's right funny buck so funny
bone Omaha Nebraska VA doing dick this
weekend you probably ain't doing dick
we just inhaled 900 milligrams a [ __ ] of
THC Wednesday at 2:00 in the afternoon
3:00 in the afternoon
in Sacramento that's a great point it's
an easy week the sushi place across the
street
Sacramento great calmly seen these
[ __ ] dr. Carroll yesterday she
caught me about something she [ __ ] had
me in tears she really is the funniest
person who Carol the girl from Seattle
he's okay yeah it's just a [ __ ] is
[ __ ] person she's got six boyfriends
you know she's got a live-in boyfriend
she's got five different guys she [ __ ]
around with like a 62 year old book she
told me she had carpal tunnel and she
told me and Liam the phone she goes I
can't even give him hand jobs at the
strip club rich old Hindu she married a
Hindu and the Hindu died and left her
like three million dollars and she went
and bought that chain of women's tennis
curves and kept buying hers in Michigan
before the bottom dropped out she sold
all six that when I can't deal to this
big gym owner
curves [ __ ] died and cattle made a
counter made out of the fat man scowling
maybe three houses a boat - cause she's
46 she's 46 years up to 46 is up she was
telling me yes fair she's taking a dump
in the boyfriend because this is the
best [ __ ] has been me this is FC Talk
this is the best my [ __ ] has been at 46
I'm the freakiest I've ever been and I'm
laughing my ass off in the cops I'm like
because she's crazy
this is I called her two years ago to
start a podcast without the camera look
of about the stripper diaries at the
dual blog she'd be up knowing that she's
got stories like I got only about sex it
is once every six months
well another book yesterday she pointed
to some they open up any club but I
should go down there I said read me the
schedule nobody I [ __ ] knew nobody
even the special events I go the flesh
yeah she listened
Clearwater Florida all comedians no not
one so I go woman out there die I can't
go down there just talk to after that
how are you what's going on with the
boyfriend he's worthless
he's on methadone it costing 112 dollars
a week I was dying
but you've got things around the house
sixteen years ago 18 years ago she still
called me twice a year but she comes out
i hook up with her and her husband
whoever she's married then the last time
I hooked up with her husband the one I
went to jail he ran over cop said stop
he said don't you gotta escape the
grease she's got the two kids with so
she goes what's up Brody Stevens healthy
I'm not stressed I'm not stressing oh I
know I have enough of an audience or I
could survive book an audition but I
want to keep doing what I'm doing
I don't stress about all getting older
that mean maybe something will come up
negative I don't know [ __ ] I don't know
oh [ __ ] look at Becky joy love I just I
have an Amex and it's been fun
I've been drumming I've been playing
baseball so I might kind of fail we want
to talk about it on the podcast I'm
excited about I went out there I played
baseball the other night played a
charity event I never haven't pitched at
a game for maybe like eight or ten years
and I went out there it was like I
hadn't missed a beat I mean I throw as
hard that played for a while but it was
like I was in a bright at home I'm a
baseball I'm a pitcher you know I do
comedy also a baseball you get nervous
out there and you can take that nervous
energy and throw it in like getting
somebody out sometimes a copy of that
nervous energy it's like nervous but
baseball is like I can I can pitch a
great occasion comedy angry you know but
I was pitching against this these high
school kids for a day and it was like I
mean they roped me they had be pretty
good but I still I was happy with I was
pleasantly
beyond surprise so as a 46 year old guy
hornacek young man though you guys are
young man Jesus [ __ ] that was 28 ha ha
oh [ __ ] what's up you bad [ __ ]
usually look at those eyeballs those are
the eyeballs of a champion [ __ ] you dare
enter this house [ __ ] are you
nuts or what
ain't one of these [ __ ] homo sapiens
walking around with [ __ ] bright eyes
telling you about pineapple Express look
at the left look at the [ __ ] ride I
look at that look at those veins in
there there's veins in there from the
quaalude days they busted them like
Cosby busted those chicks cherries
hey if you're gonna have a good time
let's have a good time by the [ __ ]
what are you gonna do you the same
anyway we're in the valley baby the San
Fernando [ __ ] Valley was the
place in the eighties that way in 84
just the music the classic rock Billy
Squier van Halen this was the spot to be
you see I'm saying not only do we smoke
reefer he and he [ __ ] edibles but you
learn about the history of Los Angeles
[ __ ] Thank You me google
everybody's all uh-oh somebody's on fire
somebody's on fire anyway we're starting
the podcast we'll see you in 10
[ __ ] minutes stay black